pleased to say the minister for
technology and digital economy chris
philp is with us this morning hi thanks
for joining us on the program want to
start with what on earth happened in
paris over the weekend i know that your
boss nadine doris wants uefa to look
into it
that's right i mean i was horrified to
see those
pictures of fans including some children
disabled fans being pepper sprayed by
french police and from the pictures i
saw there was no obvious justification
for that kind of behaviour so nadine i
think is quite right to call for uefa to
urgently investigate exactly what
happened there because we don't want to
see football fans
least of all children and disabled fans
being pepper spayed by police in the way
that we saw um so i really am concerned
by it the government are as well and we
need uefa to properly investigate
exactly what happened and get to the
bottom of it uh we've heard from a
french minister just a few moments ago
actually talking about saying that they
were sorry that children and
adults some adults have got caught up in
it but other french officials are less
sympathetic this
from the french interior uh minister
yeah uh gerald dama i
forgive my pronunciation he claimed that
stewards were assaulted by britons who
forced entry without tickets or with
counterfeit tickets tweeted about it as
well
he said thousands of british supporters
without tickets or with counterfeit
tickets forced entry and sometimes
assaulted the stewards what would you
say in response to that well i think
this is why we need a proper
investigation by uefa to get to the
bottom of it but the pictures i saw um
certainly did not depict uh british fans
liverpool fans uh doing anything of the
sword um the pictures i saw showed fans
with tickets waiting to get in uh being
sprayed and i was deeply concerned by
that i'm a football fan uh myself
uh crystal palace fan and so not really
then kidding oh oh ouch ouch
season um so um look we need to get this
investigated properly yeah um what about
the suggestions that fans were pushing
their way into the ground and they
didn't have tickets that's not the sort
of behavior that the government would
condone
no it's not of course it isn't um but as
i say we need to get this properly
looked into so we understand exactly
what happened but as i say i saw uh
footage of fans behaving in a perfectly
calm way um getting pepper sprayed and
that just strikes me looking at those
pictures as not appropriate so we need
an investigation to just get to the
bottom of all of this i think uefa are
best placed to do that and i hope they
get on with it and do it urgently talk
to me about what's going on in the
papers at the weekend suggesting that
carrie johnson's organised a couple of
parties in the downing street flat now
and that and that is continuing to
rumble on should it be investigated
well i think we've had an unbelievably
comprehensive set of investigations
going on now for a period of nearly six
months we've had obviously the su grey
investigation published last week and
we've also actually interviewed i mean
goodness knows dozens or possibly even
hundreds of people in the course of her
investigation looked at emails messages
um and everything else and we've had the
metropolitan police investigation
which again has gone over and gone on
over a number of months and they
conducted that with full police powers
so having had two separate
investigations including by the police
over many months it's not immediately
obvious to me that we need
any more investigations when this has
probably been the most rightly it's
rightly been the most thoroughly
investigated um set of incidents in in
recent times but the suggestion is that
there are um whatsapp messages that put
her in the flat on the day of the prime
minister's birthday with other people in
the apartment as well messages uh that
sue gray has not seen
for completeness should we not just look
at that yeah so i saw this story saying
that um a number 10 aide had said they
had further messages and but i also um
saw the commentary that obviously sue
gray had approached and the metropolitan
police had approached everybody i think
including this aid um over the last few
months inviting them to hand over
whatever evidence they didn't want to do
that they did they didn't want to submit
it they wanted to show it to her but not
submit it they were anxious about it
coming back to them yeah and the thing i
read in the paper and i'm simply going
on what i saw in the paper i've got no
sort of special knowledge of this
suggested that offer um to that was made
available the opportunity of showing the
message rather than giving a copy and
but it wasn't followed up i'm simply
going on what i saw um in the paper as i
said i've got no um
inside knowledge of this and but my
instinctive reaction is that there have
been two incredibly thorough
investigations that have gone on um and
unless there's something really
striking that hasn't been known about
previously then then i think they have
been looked into really thoroughly and
and the report was incredibly thorough
and another one to come obviously from
um mps so we'll wait for that um talk to
me about the ministerial code um it
looks at some of the pm's uh rewritten
forward to the ministerial code removing
all reference to honesty integrity
transparency and accountability why has
it done that well i mean the nolan
principles you're referring to i think
run through
all of public life the decision to
update this code i believe was taken and
the decision to update it in this way
was taken i think about a year ago in
april 2021 all of the uh the rules about
the importance of being honest with
parliament and all of those things are
still in there
the main change which i think is
something which the um the committee on
standards in public life called for
themselves was uh for the ability to
have a graded series of sanctions so
just like in any workplace if somebody
breaks the rules and they don't
necessarily just get fired straight away
there might be other sanctions that fall
short of getting fired and i think the
rewrite simply um confirms that
relatively common sense principle but
why would the prime minister take out
those references in his own forward that
he only wrote i think in 2019 taking out
bullying harassment honesty integrity
transparency and accountability
why would he do that now well so i mean
the forward gets updated periodically
but those those things you talked about
are of course in the in the body of the
ministerial code they haven't been
completely deleted they are still in
there and obviously things like you know
honesty integrity um proper behavior in
the workplace and so on
all of those things are still in the
ministerial code so why take the matters
are forward well because the forward is
a general introduction and i guess he
just wanted to talk about um whatever he
wanted to talk about in that forward
they're all still in the code right the
forward is just an introduction setting
the scene all of those things you've
mentioned which are obviously completely
unacceptable
are still in the ministerial code in
black and white so they're not important
enough to be in the forward though as
far as the problem general introduction
all of those things are in the
ministerial code and of course they're
important yeah but you understand why
people might be quite alarmed about that
at the moment given that the prime
minister is accused of misleading
parliament yes i do understand but the
ministerial code still makes clear that
uh misleading parliament quite rightly
is considered a breach of the
ministerial code we've been reading in
the papers this morning about some funky
new plans as far as brexit is concerned
and bringing back imperial measures
pounds and ounces and the like is that
really what people care about when
they're going to be i think 800 pounds
poorer despite what the government's
offering them um
as part of this 15 billion pound package
well i think it's just allowing a bit of
a bit of our national heritage and
culture back onto the back onto the shop
shelf and you mentioned the cost of
living and of course last week the
government announced a enormous 15
billion pound package to help the cost
of living challenges that we face and in
fact for the the uh poorest one-third of
households that support package
announced last week will amount to 1
200 pounds you know really substantial
contribution and that's on top of
everything else we've had this year the
cut in fuel duty by five p elite the
national living wage
increased by a thousand pounds per year
um two million universal credit
claimants getting an extra thousand
pounds because the taper leaf taper rate
has been adjusted so the government is
is throwing everything at this cost of
living uh problem as we rightly should
and yet and yet and yet the house of
commons library says average earner will
be 800 pounds poorer despite those
support payments
well i mean i think as the chancellor
said last last week um you know we this
is a global uh cost of living challenge
it's not happening not just in the uk
it's happening in america
in france germany across the western
world caused by a whole number of things
um the
bounce back from covid supply chain
problems in china where they're still
having lockdowns
the russia ukraine crisis a whole number
of issues
are feeding this across the western
world and what we're doing in the uk
is everything possible to try and
ameliorate and soften the the blow that
these cost of living challenges are
posing what we unveiled last week
was far more than the labour party had
proposed the package this year so far
amounts to 37 billion pounds
people are
it's well over a thousand pounds yeah um
okay it's time to celebrate isn't it um
this weekend and uh we're all going to
jubilee parties i think you're going to
won
a garden party in uh in kenley which is
in uh in my croydon constituency
apparently if you've not um
applied appealed for a license to the
council then it's too late um and you
can't have a party a street party johnny
mercer one of your colleagues um has
tweeted saying that these uh street
parties should be allowed to go ahead we
should not let killjoys spoil the
jubilee what do you think look well i
would just uh look i could fully
sympathize um with the problems you just
described i think it's fantastic we're
celebrating the queen's jubilee and i
would just say to local councils you
know around the country including mining
croydon if you do get a late application
and maybe the deadline is technically
passed i would just say to councils just
show a little bit of flexibility
show a little bit of uh willingness to
accommodate people and if you're at all
able to you know please do grant these
requests even if they are made
technically after the deadline let's
just show a bit of flexibility and
pragmatism in support of her majesty's
70th jubilee there we go lend on and up
thank you very much indeed for joining
us it's great to see you thanks a lot